fan what about this Xbox tax at the game
of
warsy hey yeah I'm I'm I'mma sit back
and and let y' cook I
think said I'm not touching that leave
alone no cuz oh no for ref for I don't
care for ref for and I got smoke for
anybody who who's talking to Xbox teag
BS cuz it's BS it's BS how about this
how about starfell sold what it sold in
in September which is awesome which is
definitely awesome to see for a new IP
but how about ain't nobody else talking
about that no more how about that how
about how about if it released the same
day as Spider-Man we all know what
really would have happened how how about
that if it would have dropped the
same never We're Never Getting Out never
get out of this I got I gotta let said
I'll leave that alone but now really I
got I got I got I gotta let him finish
his part because I got to I got to just
give him one real buff before he slide
out the door he just W you hey so all
right so so you you stepped up here was
talking about all this that the third
right so Sony put out their bundle what
what month did they put out their bundle
with Spider-Man 2o ear you would have to
educate me in September right what game
launched in September this sir what
Starfield Starfield launched in
September right okay so you had the
bundle ready you had the digital codes
you had everything in the box ready but
you said not that
dude not that
guy doing so so we said we G to move to
October we GNA do this on the 20th and
Mario said he like out that day too so
you can run from him or you going to get
this smoke and you know what Sony said
we could take our chances against the
dude that don't report digital
so report
digital top he going to report digital
he going to report physical and he going
to report every goddamn thing so we not
going to mess with that dude cuz that IP
kind of strange over there and he might
knock our socks off and if you go and
look and see how much Starfield sold
compared to uh
Spiderman we know that he would have
came up short regardless with all the
stuff that he' brought to the table King
was trying to avoid this so in order to
move you move for a reason you had to
you had everything ready you had the the
the room was set up everything was nice
but you didn't launch and you
check so I want to know why the hell the
Spider-Man run from September that's
what we doing okay that's what we doing
so so so wait a minute wait a minute
wait let's get it so so so the good
folks over there at PlayStation were so
shook so shook by our new IP that's
right terrified hold on that's riddle
with bugs and we know butth we know
talking about bugs your man got
bugs that's a man and he got bugs in
this game but let's go get it yeah and
those loading times on Starfield were
were even more egregious uh
you got a fast you got fin go ahead go
ahead where the co-op what's everything
talk to me
about so SOG that that Todd Howard uh
affectionately referred to as God Howard
correct that's right he's a god he's a
God of this yeah yeah he is he said yo
if you want my game to run right you
need the top of the top
PC that's right that's right that's
right that's what man said yeah that's
what he said and Playstation ran from
that yeah he did hold on let me get
Mario R from that too right no no Mario
said we going in October baby yeah all
right on your on your birthday listen
listen let me let me tell you something
first of all happy birthday K thank you
thank
you secondly secondly that that no
what's a Starfield what what is the
thing
that I'm so glad I brought this with me
today I am not I am not asking what it
is ask ask the average person what
Starfield is they probably don't even
know what it is or what how much did how
much did Starfield sell in the month
that they came out king you know I'm not
worried about no sales
now now now you not worry about but we
just talk about
Sal on I don't number one I don't ever
worry about sales numbers in particular
and since we all talk since okay well
I'll talk to you I'm here talk to it
probably would have sold more if it
wasn't in Game Pass but you know that's
neither here nor that but it's sold
though that's the thing that's the thing
it sold more in Game Pass and on PC and
on Xbox and it did more and it made y
move like y'all had the car y had the
car y was ready say this you had you had
Theo you had wings remember you had
wings you had to game why you had to so
all right check it out you know how I
know y didn't want to smoke you know how
here this this got get ready for work
tomorrow hustle tomorrow shout out you
know how I know y'all was scared hustle
oh yeah you know how I know y'all was
scared go ahead tell me all I need to
know y sold a
console with the digital code so the
digital code and everything was ready
y'all was ready y had the wings ready
you had the console ready y'all was
ready that's said do not hit that live
button so they going to start counting
us and this dude is rap so the new IP
looked at you and said I'm ready for
everything you got and we going to do it
in September you said you said we got
the stuff but we ain't ready to fight
though we'll we'll see you when all the
smoke calm down we going to October
don't you worry about so you implying
Spider-Man was ready for release in
September king that's what we doing was
ready and you know you know this is when
Todd this is when they bully balled
y'all Todd and them was holding the date
y'all came out and said today and Y
y'all said yeah we gonna have this game
out you know y'all know September cuz I
had the situation ready and I was
waiting for y'all and Todd said we going
in September Sony said all right see you
in
October surprise brother where did we
hit we going to go on October 20th too
oh my God this regard what y was going
to get knocked out and y'all got knocked
out Godless so you and it was buggy so
you want talk about bugs right I don't
think I think if you're a Bethesda fan I
think that's the last I think that's the
last
thing right this is it this is where
this is where the fraud alert come out
on you you got 30 years of roaches in
your
crib not the 30 years of roaches not 30
years of uncleanliness so so so 30 years
of roaches
but hustle hustle what's up the first
the first uh Spider-Man was it bufi was
it bug field I didn't play too much of
it so I
could now you reallying so you
just might have to put a fraud alert in
there right
quick might have to put a frauder save
yourself come on now God how you going
to show up and talk about two and you
ain't been there for one was you there
for miles at least I I played in B Miles
all right so so you knew that the Puerto
Rican flag shouldn't have been the
absolutely I knew that the Cuban did you
know that because I mean did you call
that part out so what how did you feel
when they came up with their own version
of Spanish like did you understand they
was really speaking Spanish and not
speaking Spanish I mean I want to
know let me tell you this shout out to
all my my Puerto Rican brothers and
sisters TJ we was offended we was
offended hey as you should be you you
really should be cuz that that was it
was broken no it was broken okay all
right so so now we talking bucks let's
talk since you think you want to take
that there
though actually I actually do I actually
do I know about that listen I'm make
listen this is definitely a video later
I'm just say that right now I'mma make
you do it to yourself this is where you
going to do it to yourself this where
yourself is going to do you in can you
or can you not say that this game has
the most games most bugs out of any name
Insomniac has ever brought to the table
if by most bugs I'm going off my own
personal Insomniac so let me CU because
I do have a bit of a history with
Inc even even from Sunset Overdrive too
right right I've had two soft locks one
in the mement park and it was like one
for like a mission select and I've had
two hard crash no one hard crash and
like a 40 hour spare and I almost got
the Platinum so I'm not saying that the
bugs aren't there I'm saying for me this
is what happened and I bought that game
day one man I went out to the midnight
release and I was playing it that night
too so for me everything seemed to work
just fine okay I'm saying all right so
all right so let's get back to the
question
I is this the most bugs in an insomniac
game that you've ever
played I mean three of them dog you
talking about three could you answer the
question sir is it's the
most top start I'm trying I'm trying to
think I'm trying to think back to M
Moralis uhhuh was it I don't think it
was that bad I don't think Ratchet and
Clank because I played and beat that one
I'm I'm about to end of that one that
one wasn't that bad either not like
this stop his game I don't I'm okay with
with the quote bugs I'm I'm okay with
cuz my experience didn't really stop me
from playing it was you talk about three
you talk
okay can we get back to my question hold
on before I even get back to your
question all right go ahead sir how how
was the cuz I'm assuming you played in
Beast Starfield correct all right listen
listen listen let's get to
this that as no how manys did you sir
sir sir sir sir sir before before I
answer your question because I'm GNA do
a whole lot faster than you I want you
to answer the question is this the most
bugs that you've ever encountered in an
insomniac game yes or no sir sir it's
it's it's only hard for me to answer
that because my time with M as Morales
I'm trying to figure out that I have
that much best not forget that s part I
honestly can't remember sir so you so
you misremember
sir to Mis don't do it like that don't
do it like
that so I'm going to take that I'm going
to take I'm going take that as a yes
this is the most bugs that you have
encountered Inn game and I'm tell you
this I I I've encountered one bug in
Starfield I told you the woman was
floating and I had to I had come back
what's that game where the what's what's
that game where since the battle has
been
decided so so we go we go we we we the
beef off is over now right can we move
on hold on hold on I just want to say I
just want to say to the real like I have
anything to do today I I just want to
say to the real it's
official don't come for me unless I send
for you cuz I'll finish you off but God
bless hustle and motive shout out one
number one hold on let me go get
something hustle
because you can figure out if you can
remember by the time I come back oh
that's cute stop being hustle before you
go please tell where they can find you
cuz you hilarious and you got to go to
work and we're not trying to get nobody
fired so where they can find it's it's
it's tomorrow I just wake up at 3:00 in
the morning um hindsight but hustle was
my new channel I'll tweet y'all so y'all
can just tweet it back out so I actually
Focus I actually focus on a retro gaming
content um so a few of the Spider-Man
games that were spoken about earlier
like we shadows and I played Shadow
Dimensions just recently I kind of like
that game too even though the camera was
kicking my behind I'm just going to
focus on like the Retro stuff it's just
something that I really enjoy um that's
why I'm super excited about uh Super
Mario RPG and pretty much everything
after that uh
K is there anyone else hold on hold on
hold on before before you before you
finish no no no he I finished already do
he done am I though because I I believe
the game one of the games that I really
enjoy playing this year or two of the
games that I really enjoy playing this
year up for game of the year uh nominees
how about uh
Starfield we doing it
now this like a perfect transition to
the to the last topic let's get to the
last topic Xbox this sounds like a
perfect transition to the last topic
Xbox tax let's go all right so U we that
we're going to now do that um yeah so it
looks like the streets are talking y'all
the streets are talking obviously see y
man apprciate you guys
apprciate God bless all
all you in your absence I do all good I
do want to I do want to throw a red flag
on the on the
and say King has no right to complain
about the the the length of the show
today yes
yes it was like three beef offs that I
had to deal listen hip
hop Hip Hop look at that you gotta be
calling you hip-hop cuz normally hip hop
bring this type of smoke so hustle and
motivate I hope you have a blessed day
sir and um I want you to go back and
understand we made you
move you know what just go just go with
it you could have played that game
incept setember but we gave you a
September to remember have a blessed day
it's all good Video Game Awards y'all
just watch the Video Game Awards and
watch Starfield not be
nominated yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
Spider-Man get beat
salute be a messy out the door salid be
a two time
loser looking crazy
so your man they got a
shot
better shot y'all
I'm he shot a shot on the
way he get the last word he had to get
the last word and they gave your man
that easy entrance to get a go ahead you
got know
man all right uh final topic I think